[Music]
you taking me to school again and
picking up part of some drill ain't no
drill 19 men attacked our country the 12
of you will be the first ones to fight
back how do you love your family and
leave them to go to war I have two hours
I'll be really quick not a chance
holding out is the only way I can get
into you come back to me what's gonna be
only a week every step we take is gonna
be a minefield from a hundred different
wars we take that city World Trade
Center is just the beginning
teaming up the general of the Northern
Alliance we know nothing about general
you show me exactly where we're going
over the mountains we take horses
all right who's ridden before anyone
summer camp when I was nine spring break
but I was pretty hammered
does have a name the name gray this is
we slide
we're outnumbered 50,000 Taliban
al-qaeda fighters we're on our own I
can't order anyone to do this you want
to surrender keep your finger on the
trigger stay there okay
[Music]
there's no playbook here we have to
write it ourselves
oh I ain't losing one man honest - you
could stand me up at the gates of war
fight with horsemen against tanks
the greatest weapon in yes very no easy
way and if you die that's a letter you
and your wife we're gonna wish you wrote
I made you a promise
come along
[Music]
at 12 strong the declassify true story
of the horse soldiers
[Music]
you